it is all about comic book royalty here
in London starting with the king of the
seven seas Aquaman himself Jason Momoa
this action-packed
origin story also stars Nicole Kidman
and Amber Heard I'm going to swim for
God's sakes maybe you are throwing that
well but Jason's big fish out of water
movement just might be his next gig
he'll be hosting Saturday Night Live
next week breaking news
you're hosting SNL hold on bucket list
Mary Lisa wanna be on SNL I'm done are
you nervous
no I'm excited good Lisa come on and do
a sketch meanwhile Aquaman's fellow
Justice leaguer Wonder Woman aka gal
gadot twas also in London for the
premiere of her new movie Ralph breaks
the Internet
the animated sequel generated over 84
million dollars at the holiday box
office may because she sings a duet with
Sarah Silverman
[Music]
I always practice without knowing what
for it's been the first time I've ever
sang in a movie and it's been great and
they really liked it the cast braved the
cold weather to greet fans outside I
mean seriously the whole thing is that
what girls shouldn't have to be
uncomfortable to deserve love and I'm in
a dress in the freezing cold it's
ridiculous but all john c reilly wanted
to do was finally meet gal she was
making I wonder when someone we were
recording so I haven't met her yet
I'm hoping to tonight and we asked gal
to give us something anything about
Wonder Woman 1984 and here's what she
did
two thumbs up I'd say that's a good sign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]